CBS News contributor ed O'Keefe is a
congressional reporter for The
Washington Post he's on Capitol Hill
Edie you're just about as plugged in as
anybody there tell us what's going to
happen well as the president said it's
pretty nasty Nora and it looks as if the
Senate will around midday today try to
settle this will either plunge into a
shutdown or they may come up with some
kind of 11th hour deal that keeps the
government open just a few more days in
an attempt to sort out all these issues
but Republicans have said no we don't
want to do that the offers on the table
you either vote for it or you don't if
you're a Democrat votes against this
we're gonna make you pay for it
well Paul Ryan said the only people
standing in the way of this or the
Democrats so the blame game is certainly
under way who will be to blame if the
government does shutdown yell if you ask
folks around here you're right
Republicans will say Democrats Democrats
will say Republicans some people who
work at the White House say it's all of
Congress everyone's going to shoulder
the blame here a little bit but remember
the issue in the Senate is that while
Republicans control the place narrowly
they require getting Democratic votes in
order to hit a 60-vote threshold to
avoid these procedural blocks that can
happen to these kinds of bills and
Democrats have been saying if you want
our votes sure we'll fund the government
but there are some priorities that we
have that we want to address the big one
of course is the fate of these immigrant
dreamers this has been on the table
since it since September when the
president started the clock on the
program ending in March and they say why
not do it now when everyone's got a vote
on a bill that they are ultimately going
to support ed when President Obama was
in office they used to scream at
Republicans who would hold up these
funding measures and try and get things
the way Democrats are now trying to do
this with daca are Democrats totally
unified in this strategy to use this
moment for leverage on daca no you will
see a handful of Democrats today vote
with Republicans to keep the government
open how many we don't exactly know but
all of them are running for re-election
this year in states that Donald Trump
won by double digits in 2016 they know
they're going home to face voters who
lean Republican and who want to see
Democrats working with Republicans
so they'll stick with the Republicans in
this case but others most of the
Democrats will vote against this all
right ed O'Keefe always good to see you
thank you very much